january 1st is typically a day when laws
passed in the previous year go into
effect christina ruffini has a look at
some across the country that are going
on the books
from marijuana
to minimum wage 1588
across the country are ringing in 2022
with new laws that will go into effect
in the new year the nation's capital
will join 15 states where recreational
pot is legal
you can get high in big sky
or by grass in the garden state today we
are ending a 90-year
[Music]
prohibition and new york will become the
second largest state after california
where it's legal to light up
and while the federal minimum wage has
stayed stuck at 7.25 an hour since 2009
25 states will be upping theirs in the
next year with most topping 10 dollars
an hour
in california pigs will get better pens
and chickens will be able to spread
their wings with tough new welfare
regulations for farm animals in the
state although they're likely to be
challenged in court
washington state and delaware will
restrict single-use plastic including
bags and takeout utensils
connecticut will allow granny pods or
garage apartments to be rented out in
residential areas and single family
homes thank you guys for supporting me
and in illinois haley martinez inspired
a new law that will allow kids under 16
to run a lemonade stand without a permit
after hers was shut down by the health
department if she's got the initiative
to rent a lemonade stand she should be
able to make a little money running a
lemonade stand city leaders gave her a
new better lemonade stand now that her
pores are all above board
for cbs saturday morning christina
raffini washington